invité de ce journal à l'occasion d'une
intégrale de ses oeuvres au zénith voici
avec nous serge gainsbourg mais d'abord
une petite précision c'est quelque chose
de tout à fait exceptionnel puisque
cette intégrale des oeuvres au zénith et
tous supports donc nous avons des
compactes vidéo des contacts normaux
nous avons des cassettes des 45 tours et
également des disques serge gainsbourg
bonjour vous regardiez le journal tout à
l'heure et je vous ai vu réagir à la à
la formidable bataille politique qui est
en train de se mettre en route ça vous
inspirer oui je citerai une phrase de
bossuet
que l'avocat la défense de flaubert
faubert est attaquée format la bovary
pour
pour l'audace de madame aubry
et avocats citer cette phrase que
bonchamp jamot haut lieu de la vie
décent je mets un public auquel autre
chose que la politique qu un mouvement
alternatif qui passe
au dégoût et du dégoût l'appétit l'âme
flottant toujours incertaine entre
l'ardeur qui se renouvelle et l'ardeur
qui sera là au tibet dans ce mouvement
alternatif
perpétuelle on ne laisse pas de se
divertir par l'image d'une liberté hier
vous savez faire court et en plus vous
avez résumé tout à fait parfaitement et
très poétiquement une opinion politique
serge gainsbourg donc l'intégrale de vos
oeuvres au zénith c'est c'est tout cela
en première mondiale première mondiale
c'est un sacré tas de d'oeuvre est ce
que c'est un coup de producteurs ou
est-ce que c'est déjà une certaine façon
quand on a 60 ans d'écrire ses mémoires
61 61
je n'ai pas encore cassé ma pipe
chiffres quels sont les meilleurs
moments quels sont les meilleurs moments
que vous gardez du zénith les meilleurs
souvenirs que vous gardez du zénith or
je pense que c'est toutes ces
gamins et gamines
les botia lui mais c'est comme un ciel
étoilé et j'avais l'image qu'on a que
traditionnellement de serge gainsbourg
c'est ce fameux billet de 500 balles
conques ramon plein sur un plateau c'est
gainsbourg qui va chez drucker et qui
voit whitney houston et qui dit comme ça
alors que le micro état je me lasse au
très bien passé moi l'expression
messieurs dames s'est fait fait et qui
alors un âge canonique on peut plus et
quatre années
et c'est eux c'est les éveils j'avais on
a raison de le dire et puis c'est aussi
gainsbourg qui revient sur le billet de
500 balles mairie et tout habillé et
c'est gainsbourg qui a la une de globe
se montre dans un costume de fric et qui
dit à l'intérieur pas de flics nombre de
fric fric il est affable labsus mais
c'est pas ça fait du bien de faire des
lapsus et qui dit par exemple je gagne
3,5 milliards de centimes par an je m'en
fous je le dépense est ce que le ce
gainsbourg provoc c'est toujours le
l'image qu'on peut avoir bien sûr parce
que j'ai jamais julmy j'ai vu passer
le racket du fisc
sur air kabyle c'est pour char à ce que
vous dites simples
vous auriez vous négociez avec charasse
une réduction de vos impôts
le chara je ne connais que la case n
caserne d'arras où j'étais
soldat en
1948 donc ensuite j'étais un camp
disciplinaire
qui étaient 50 pas la frileuse voulais
quand même bien rendu aux militaires
vous avez un truc là un truc rouge pour
vert du veston en apparence et une
décoration vous n'avez pas c'est quoi ce
serait ça s'appelle par illicite de
décoration par contre est-ce que vous
croyez que je peux être accusé de
complicité
jeune homme on va voir les passes et pas
assez
non en fait je suis officier des arts et
lettres
mais je peux faire le rouge
félicitations il ya des petits rockeurs
qui
croient ça va arriver comme ça va durer
moi je dure plus que ça fait 30 ans que
tu as cru
increvable mais quand même on a je
lisais un petit bout d'interviews de
vous il n'ya pas très longtemps on vous
dit que vous avez arrêté l'alcool
oui les médecins voire interdit l'alcool
m
parce que le diagnostic est et le sud
doivent alors vous perdez a vu en deux
ans et vit
ou titre aussi quelque part là que vous
êtes capable complètement d'accepter
aujourd'hui le fait que le que la
laideur est supérieure à la beauté
ah ça c'est pas moi la laideur est
supérieure à la beauté en ce sens
qu'elle dure
c'est pas des yeux
c'est pas moi j'en ai une autre ce qui
me gêne la jument c'est là que
ça c'est classe super c'est moi c'est
vraiment super g et regardez
j'ai presque prête à piquer un peu
bamboo
vous écrivez aussi encore un scénario de
film qu'isabelle qui va s'appeler stan
the flasher est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression que dans les films vous
êtes toujours planté pourquoi est-ce que
vous persistez on se souvient de jean
etc mais bon pour le reste les vrais
films c'est pas tout à fait bien ce
bourg si
je dis on al'impression je suis poli
parce que vous êtes là
truffaut a dit ceci
dit je t'aime moi non plus restera dans
les
annales
les cinémathèques voilà donc vous avez
l'impression que ces films resteront au
moins parce que ces gosses et signés
gainsbourg orvoine on va tous ont un bon
réalisateur
jeudi un pas
d'accord non tact et on remarquera qu'en
plus vous les montrez votre briquet
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
viennent ici qui sont très riches et qui
ont des briquet en or vous avez un zippo
classique est vraiment l'eau
allez-y
c'est ce gars ce bourg je suis obligé de
van persie est quand même en plus
attention parce que de 2,1 soit ça va
chier pour pas ce que je fais lunettes
noires là je c'est vrai que vous êtes
encore sur antenne 2
formidable c'est très bien de choisir
cette chaîne vous avez rendez vous allez
on a rendez vous avec vous à quelle
heure demain soir à travers trois
là vous en avez déjà dit pas mal parce
que ça va
encore eu peut-être dans le corps une
citation ou une citation à d'accord on
va j'ai quelques à fente à 6 jan
aphorismes deux oscars est super alors
allons-y pour la cerise que je suis un
cynique mais oscar wilde elle dit ceci
le cynisme c'est connaître le prix de
tout et la valeur de rien
dont acte d merci je rappelle donc
nouveau recevions à l'occasion de ce qui
sort actuellement je crois que c'est
lundi 10 avril c'est-à-dire l'intégrale
de vos oeuvres au zénith tous supports
et ça c'est une première mondiale touché
port il ya donc des cassettes des
compactes vidéo des compactes ordinaire
cassettes vhs disque dur etc enfin il y
a tout ce que vous voulez de gainsbourg
dans tous les formats et on nous annonce
également pour octobre 89 une intégrale
cette fois de toutes vos jeunes
[Musique]